[Music]
now if you're interested in learning
this
follow along i'm going to break this up
into small steps
so that you can systematically get to a
point where you can play at full speed
[Music]
to that we're going to add a fifth on
top
now let's change the fingering to one
four
two five two five
and two five to that we're just going to
add
one more note to the third and fourth
beats
here a tenth above
and same for the fourth one get used to
rolling the third chord
you can also do it with the fourth but
it's really crucial for
the third one now we have our left hand
let's review
we can now move on to the right hand and
first we're going to concentrate on the
pinky
the fifth finger only playing the
following line
[Music]
and there's an exception here at the end
i'm using my third finger
now to those pitches we're just going to
concentrate on the first three with the
following rhythm
and we're going to add two notes with
our thumb
f sharp and e
now to the notes that we are using our
thumb width so f sharp and e we're going
to stack
two more notes on top
now let's break those block chords apart
maybe at this point bring in the left
hand
see how it feels and let's actually fill
that in
with another note at the end
repeating that e an octave above with
the thumb again
maybe try this slightly faster
now to this we're just going to add two
more notes one here
this a sharp and then
this f sharp at the top
[Music]
try it with the left hand
now at this point i would suggest
memorizing this whole measure
with both hands
now the next two parts i'm going to hone
in on what i believe is
one of the most tricky parts of this
whole phrase
so the first part is
[Music]
these three notes so we ended here
with the e and f sharp we're gonna dip
down with our fourth finger and play
the d sharp and try to make that as
smooth as possible
and also lift your wrist like so
but really find what feels the best
so that you're able to play this
with relative ease from here we're
actually going to backtrack a little bit
and focus on the notes leading up to
these three pitches
so this whole run here
and you have to get used to this stretch
so for this i would suggest
repeating these block chords
now break those notes apart notice that
this
g-sharp here doesn't exist in the actual
phrase but we're
playing it anyway just so that we get
used to
this positioning now
switch it over to play those
[Music]
this turn around i guess
[Music]
and now let's move on to the second
measure we're gonna start off on an
octave
from d-sharp with fingers one and four
this fingering is crucial
and then an octave with
b but with an e in the middle
now to this we're going to just add one
more note in between
which is the a sharp using our fourth
finger so this might feel a little
awkward because you're
repeating that fourth but that's it
just the a sharp now break up these
notes so that we're playing single notes
[Music]
[Applause]
let's add in that rolled chord in the
left hand
and we are very very close now
from those last three pitches we're
going to
repeat our thumb the same pitch b to b
notice that i have the petal down as
well i didn't mention
anything about it but feel free to use
it or not
during all these steps now to that let's
add a fourth
on top so this e with our second finger
now let's add one more note the f sharp
with our third finger
[Applause]
you see it needs work
so now we're actually going to revisit
the transition point from measure one
to two let's start from that bottom most
note the e here
and connect those two measures let's use
our left hand as well
and i would build up in tempo
add in that f sharp
now let's take care of that end
for that focus on those top notes
f-sharp g-sharp c-sharp
three four five
and if you've made it this far this
should be
relatively easy now let's review
in terms of pedal i'm just changing
after each cord
so four times make sure you don't go on
to the next one
before you master each one so really
take a systematic approach even though
you feel like you can just
have a go at it from the get-go have a
great day and i'll see you soon